[Music]
the sigh is done we head to the second
chamber of three
kids chamber of
there's nothing wrong with three they do
trilogies of three
it's a magic number yeah it is they were
you know
men and a woman had a little baby
yeah they did it was three in the family
that's a magic magic number anyway
animals you want to talk about good
songwriting man
you like remember that [ __ ] from 40
years ago yeah schoolhouse rock
rocked it was it because they got us at
a young age or is it because
yeah there was a in the 90s a lot of
90s musicians covered all the
schoolhouse rock songs
i had that i had that album that was uh
shannon hoon covered that poor thing
and uh did a beautiful version shannon
hoon from blind melon
yeah let me give you a little inside
dope when jennifer schwabach the woman i
eventually married the one who wears the
kev
[ __ ] jacket that you're that you gave
her jane swallow it's not ringing any
bells
um she uh was dating a dude who was um
from high school and stuff who wound up
being like uh
i don't know if it was a roadie or
whatever the [ __ ] on
with blind melon so she went on tour
with blind melon oh really yeah
did she meet the little bee girl she did
cool but yeah and then that boy
died right yeah he passed away sadly
i can say is that my life is pretty
plain
that's a song right i think my life is
getting gray
is what he says those the lyrics i i
think maybe not
i mean i know my life is getting gray
jeez look at you
yeah [ __ ] reed richards laughs at you
he's like
i only got stripes on the side yeah i
got the white walls look at that guy
you're on your way to uh go ahead
dare i say that is a a nearing mike
pence head of hair
do i have a fly in my head is that what
you're saying oh my god
well remembered all right we're in the
phi speaking of fly
it's the phone 29 years of marriage i'm
looking for those
that are sex punch up from you i need
those lines
don't forget number one you're a fish
[ __ ] number two here comes a face full
of millet
um not you can't even remember the word
what is the word
mill it i said mill it it's not millet
what is it
it's melt milt i don't know here it
comes
in the monster that's right milty milton
the monster
here comes [ __ ] milt milk
does the body good god
yup all those mnemonics i gave you
earlier none of them seem to work
all right so we'll move on you know that
mullet that was getting his face eaten
he [ __ ] launched a [ __ ] face full
of milt at the bird to get his feathers
all stuck together
but the birds like i like it i like it
when the prey comes
when the prey comes kevin smith's
thrilling autobiography well that'll be
when i actually get you out into the
[ __ ] woods and you get to see some
birds and you're that's
gonna be your memoir five minutes you
spend in nature
i am bothering no birds bro like
bathroom birds i have a big long lens
you're bothering birds man if i'm a bird
and i'm in my nest and i look over i'm
like you're bothering me
i don't care
come here kid and they get a lot of kids
right they have like many birds
at once baby birds chicks or whatever
[ __ ]
so yeah there's words for all of those
things dude could be like chick chick
puke and then [ __ ] chick puke and then
chick chick
puke that's the comment that's the comic
superhero
but that's our light well he's picking
up all the chicks because they're one
they're one shot a piece they're not
even as good as a darren george
[Music]
um all right what are we doing for the
okay we're gonna
put to rest
animal urban legends there's a lot of
myths about animals
and we're going to begin cats sleep on
like you can steal your breath if it
sleeps on your chest or whatever the
[ __ ]
that's one but we're not going to cover
that because it's stupid what i'm saying
of that nature
that kind of milt yeah i mean the big
ones are really things that people still
believe
is what i'm trying to we're myth busting
here
but without breaking any copyrights or
um
you know violating any laws uh
for myth buzzers why don't you do this
[ __ ] make it milk busters instead
nobody's [ __ ] competing for that
title
yeah because it's terrible milk busters
is all about us we go out at night to
bust in some milk no we go out at night
at fisheries
with flashlights when they're all
[ __ ] and then we turn the light on
real quick
okay okay you're the milk botter
yeah the milk bottle man was like what
the book and then you know
they're all surprised and they pull out
and they just [ __ ] come
so we and then we go in for a tight shot
like look at that
they don't pull out there most fish they
lay the female lays her eggs and then
the male
goes over them and releases the mills
and
many do they just [ __ ] they many do not
i mean
sharks do but in a weird way but
they most many fish only do it once
so like a salmon swims upstream the
females they go
[ __ ] forever their bodies change
their heads get these humps on them
they go up these they avoid bears they
just get all the way up these uh
streams and once they get there the
streams are oftentimes
too small for them to swim in they lay
the eggs they spread the melt
and they do it once and then they die
and their death their slow horrifying
semi life and you know they
they degrade feeds the young
when they're born so they give their all
and it happens once
what do you mean like so they're dying
bodies when the fish are born they're
like
fertilizes the stream and gives uh
material for the fish to
the the new hatched fish to eat
thank god peter parker didn't get that
[ __ ] ability yeah
spiderman spiderman comes once and then
dies
the spider melt man he's like you take
some of this [ __ ] spider milk
and you're eight and you're right in
your eight eyes hmm
dies because he's [ __ ] another spider
it's not like he'd [ __ ] that's person
yeah you're right i forgot that he's
really is spider-man and not any of the
other creatures that we've been making
him for the last six years
what is the uh what speaking of
creatures
the first urban myth you'd like me to
bust bust it man
lemmings commit suicide what lemmings
commit suicide that's always basically
[ __ ] do that's the name of my
acapella group that i'm still in is the
lenin's
fleming's i thought it was lemmings
commit suicide that's the way funny
[ __ ]
name well no it's just lines uh
lemmings don't go running over cliffs
they don't and it started a lot earlier
than we than we had thought we touched
on this in an earlier podcast sometime
in the last
millennium and um but starting back
in the 1530s a geographer proposed that
they actually fell from the sky during
storms
and the most popular rumor is that they
commit mass suicide when they migrate
that one lemming goes and the rest of
them just follow
and that's just not true and when disney
made their 1958 academy award-winning
documentary
called white white wilderness
they couldn't get the lemmings to jump
off the cliff
so they built a turntable and
put it mounted a camera on it they put
lemmings on it and they spun it around
so the library was like what they
had off they went they faked it because
they couldn't get them to do the
behavior that people had believed for so
long
and so that was known as the great
lemming massacre of 1956.
disney lemming massacre and it turns out
like
the stuff in bambi isn't true either
what do you mean
it didn't really happen just like the
lemmings
it's a disney joke i thought you were
saying like you know bambi's not really
a deer
it's a [ __ ] stag [ __ ] or something
no
um a little joke because it's a cartoon
well don't joke around when it comes to
like [ __ ] all i can think now is like
walt disney gone
like they're like mr disney they won't
go over the cliff it's just not their
natural behavior he's like i'm walt
[ __ ] disney and i want these lemmings
to go over the [ __ ] cliff now you
build a little
disc it seems like it's fun but it's
gonna make him dizzy enough to
fall off this [ __ ] so we can make
white
wilderness says the white man you hear
me
yeah that all seems plausible
that's [ __ ] crazy dude that's crazy
it's crazy it's like me going like you
know
[ __ ] um what's an animal i don't like
it's like saying this polly doesn't want
a cracker
well we're going to make him want a
cracker and just starve them
and jam it down every polly wants a
cracker though
this is like you know
like [ __ ] the elephant having a
little dick
not one that can be a third leg okay
it's just like that it's exactly like
that what's the other
what other there's other things earwigs
still believe that earwigs live inside
of your ears
not helped by star trek ii the wrath of
khan
yeah where chekhov says they put
creatures
in our bodies this is city alpha 5.
any opportunity to get some uh to get
some wrath of khan out of kevin
yes um my friend i could say only this
of all the souls i have encountered on
my journeys
his was the most
he's got a fly in his mouth
[Music]
human
one of my favorite performances um and a
fantastic moment man like
it's such a great like [ __ ]
a really nice way to send off
like a character that had been those two
cats have been together since the
beginning man you never thought you'd
see [ __ ] spock without kurt
and if anyone was going to die you'd
think it'd be [ __ ] kirk but
spock man just the needs of the many
that way the needs of the
of the few or the one or the one
yeah i love that i never took the
kobayashi meru
test how do you like my solution
i'm over here spock you're talking to
the wall
yeah [ __ ] hey can you see me
remember when he bumps into the wall
when he walks over he's like
[Music]
well he's filled with some sort of
fantasy radiation
dude i ain't [ __ ] saying it's bad i'm
just like
that's [ __ ] i can't believe they let
that stay in the cut
like that's it's real that's what would
happen
and nobody had the sense to be like this
looks a little goofy and they're like
[ __ ] no
because it works well they left the
storm trooper hitting his head on the
way into the detention
uh wing and in star wars so
i guarantee you that he didn't see that
until like the third or fourth [ __ ]
public screen
maybe even until the third or fourth
year of star wars he was too busy
counting money
well uh it turns out that the earwig is
um
ear wiggler in anglo-saxon uh mean
is pronounced irrika and they
they think that the earwig is called in
the earwig because
peop you would it was some like thing
that people did where you flatten it out
when you catch it
and it looks like an ear when you
flatten it and kill it
so it never once went inside it doesn't
go in your ear
does not lay eggs you don't slowly go
mad like the
roald dahl story it is anything
go into your ears besides like bacteria
is there any insect that's like i think
i'll try it out
i don't know like the capybara for your
ears you know the capybara fish
but the one that goes up your dick hole
yeah yeah that never happened
that never happened it only happens to
female cattle as they're crossing a
river and
if they pee it can swim through their p
stream
but it can't like make its way up the
urination stream of a person peeing
so no none of these should bend up a
human's dick that's all
you snopes and that [ __ ] unless somebody
pranked him
and was like kevin doesn't know that
we've replaced his
his condom with a we took a fish
no candy road not capped by our
candieroo fish we took a fish with only
half a face and stuffed it and stuck it
up his dick
and told him that it's a capybara
fish no it's a candiru candy roofish
yeah can do do this man can do
this um all right last one
last one there's only three this week i
apologize to those hungry for knowledge
but we have three
and look how much time it's cut down on
we've only been recording for an
hour and 55 minutes three's only imagine
how much more time it would be if we had
ten more examples
camels no store water in their house
they do not store water in their humps
they store them they're able to
absorb water in their red blood cells
swell up in size because they're not
disc shaped
they're uh what's the right word
they are oval shaped red blood cells
so they actually can they can saturate
their bloodstream with water
and over time lose it their humps their
humps their lovely
camel lumps are
filled with fat that's why they can go
for so long without
eating and they can go for a long time
without drinking because
they have these specialized red blood
cells now let me ask you about the hump
yeah if they're if you're feeding a
camel all the time
is the do the humps the humps are
storing the fat
but if the camel ain't eating for a
month the humps get smaller
the hump does get smaller if they don't
eat
can they how long do they have it's like
a ticking clock like if the hump gets
down by two feet they're [ __ ] dead
yes
look at my hump i can hardly see it i'm
half the hump i used to be
and hump a little carlu goes away
so there lies the phi
and phi we're through two chambers we've
emptied one of the derringers man we got
two shots left ladies and gentlemen
and it begins with the why why
so you know the wise we'll often uh
have people ask questions about science
and other things that are
interesting but they'll also ask
questions that are posers for kevin
to give his own take on and so we'll
begin with any of those in the
in the why okay that is from jonathan
waters
or the john waters at the john waters
jonathan
waters wants to know why why
um so he says what do they mean by spice
in
dune what could spice actually be
coke right cocaine it's like the cocaine
that turns your eyes blue
it makes my brown eyes blue and it works
like
like acid because it's like isn't it
open up your mind and [ __ ] like that
suddenly you're like i have no fear fear
is the mind killer
well doesn't it also turn like the the
navigators
into those hideous don't they feed it to
the fetuses and turn them into those
hideous monsters turns it into a giant
[ __ ] face thing it's just like
it looks like [ __ ] cuado man but real
big and [ __ ]
yeah and gross and it looks like a giant
bug from [ __ ]
starship troopers where [ __ ] uh
doogie houser was like
it's afraid and they were like yeah
we've scared a bug that was like
literally the climax of that movie yeah
like
got him and he's afraid are you scared
of us best time ever
and dude he's like scary we scared this
[ __ ] thing man
you [ __ ] bug that's how i met your
mother he's like
that's it i said
your joke's more current than mine i
went for a [ __ ] doogie i was a
reference
that just goes to show you that i did
not watch how i met your mother
well i'm the first joke i made was um uh
best time ever and nobody watched that
oh
that's right that was the nbc show
wasn't it it was
or so um oh
so why hi was that was
that was what what is spice and you
think it's like a
it's it's comparable to a hardcore drug
that of this in the 60s when the books
were written
like acid lsd or something because it
expands your mind make sure
your eyes blue makes your balls suck up
into your body you're all dick
no [ __ ] balls all meat no veg
and you're like will they ever come back
but you don't care because you're on the
spies
you want to know where your balls go
they grow huge and they [ __ ] become
third stage travelers man
you can fold space with your in inhaled
balls [ __ ] yeah
or do there's a whole universe down
there granted only one person ever came
out of it but still
universe of one okay next question comes
from scrump
underscore
um he says
there's evidence that shows that ancient
animals
on the whole were much bigger than
current day animals
are animals getting smaller to the point
where they'll all just be the size of
chihuahuas
they'll never get that small but they
will continue to get smaller and smaller
the closer we get to the sun
is wait it hasn't we're not getting
closer to the sun
if you were paying attention clearly
you're on a [ __ ] five
ten second delay i was going for an
actual answer here but i'll let you
continue that's usually the rhythm we
have
people get to see me look at the notes
i've made
i feel like animals like they figured it
out they're like all they do is
eat us and ride us and hit us
so let's start giving them less to eat
and ride
and hit let's [ __ ] take it small man
we'll keep shrinking
until these [ __ ] leave us alone who's
with me
who's with me and some [ __ ]
i don't know [ __ ] giraffe talked a
minute what's the smartest animal in the
world um
dolphins some dolphin talked him all
into it
he just used his power of his squeaky
power of persuasion
he's still cute do what he wants look at
that dolphin any cute
blowhole i could come in handy
i can't believe you could say the word
blowhole and not give me five minutes on
it
i mean i'm telling you this isn't that
like
that's where you're like people like hey
fish
what's your blowhole and you're like
that's where the milk comes out
yeah and the thing is your impression of
me is dead on
that's the weird thing to me is it's
like it sounds like i'm even saying it
please write that down and say that to
johanna
that is a good line no my blood
is where the milk comes out here the
milk's coming out the blue hole they go
you pitch 20 send them to me
i'll pick the ones i like fair enough
um but the melts coming out the blowhole
is a pretty hot way to
all right it sounds like this is
something you may want to say to your
wife
she won't make sense i'd have to explain
it she'd be like the milt's come on
well i'm like yeah because andy's
nickname is fish
she'd be like what does that have to do
with this and why are you [ __ ] saying
it to me i'm like well andy won't say it
she's like it would make more sense if
andy said i'm like that's what i [ __ ]
said
but andy won't say because he's a little
[ __ ] puss because he's a little
[ __ ] blowhole
yes i understand this is the moment of
the heat of passion
but i really don't understand the logic
behind something that andy would
make more sense saying than you i'm like
it don't matter i can't
and you're like what you don't listen to
the podcast
she does you don't listen to any podcast
she don't even listen to the one she's
on
while she's recording at shane she's not
even listening
she don't even listen i don't even know
if she knows that i'm still here
[ __ ] she's like you stay down in that
office you got a fist full of milk
i'm like well here is the reason behind
animals getting smaller it's that the
temperature of the earth
is rising larger animals have more
difficulty surviving in a hotter
environment and they think that it's
going to continue and that animals will
continue to get smaller
but this is a point of controversy in
the scientific community
many scientists believe they will
continue to get smaller others say
something's got to give that's all i
have for you on that
what um what would give like you know
they're like look sooner or later these
[ __ ] are gonna start eating the lower
halves of these other [ __ ] faces
and their upper halves are gonna have to
watch
yes that is exactly their thinking best
defense they got against a predator is a
face full of [ __ ] milk man you go out
like a [ __ ] fish you got one chance
to save the rest of your body you ain't
ever getting your fish chin back
but with a face full of milk you at
least live half a life
under the sea granted you're [ __ ]
everything down there is going in your
mouth
like other fishes milk [ __ ] fish poo
tell me about it oh he's back
[Laughter]
finally a little cameo from our old
friend
yeah well
uh one last question to get us to three
questions in the why
i have one last question
will you kill me
i don't care to speed to the ocean i'll
take my
chances but living in a bowl by myself
swimming around with my own poo and milk
i got to add milk see i did learn
something
i jerk off because i have nothing to do
but then i
don't have any paper [ __ ] towels
so the milk just floats around and
sometimes i forget it's there and i
breathe it in
i breathe my whole [ __ ] believe that
kill me [ __ ] put my bubble on
the stove i don't want to live
i'm so glad the world got to see that
when you're not actually
talking you just continue to do this
that's called staying in character the
commitment to the bit isn't it yeah
[ __ ] miss meryl streep
she would stop when she wasn't doing
lines she'd be like what would be the
point with her eyes all closed and [ __ ]
but my point is like you keep doing it
even when you're not talking
because you will be talking soon we got
to make the
goldfish movie and have jared leto's
star in it
so that like for six months of his life
he's just like this the whole time
just at dinner like once people are like
what is wrong with them
like he's on some kind of drug like no
he's doing a goldfish movie for sure
he can totally make i don't know if we
get a whole [ __ ] goldfish movie out
of it but like a series
22 minutes a piece of that [ __ ] sad
fish
um okay one more one more one more why
and that is from that adam lee
uh that emily writes adam lee
that adam lee adamly
do it all adamly you can't [ __ ] do it
like if you can't do it
right do it adamly yeah his name is is
basically an adverb i went um i had a
good friend in college and her mother's
maiden name was titus
and everyone in their family sounded
like a disease martha titus
richard titus they all had some titis
that's fun man so i'm going to use that
in my pitch tomorrow
like what does that have to do with
anything i'm like i don't know it's a
funny i just
i forgot the thing i was going to say so
i'll say this yeah it's going to have to
can you give me two seconds i just need
to text him what was the [ __ ] thing
that i said that i was going to do
they're like did you just say your text
out loud as you write it i was like
that's how i work
give me why are you doing this kevin
then i'm not mad
then i'm getting mad because andy's not
answering fast enough and i'm like
doesn't he know i'm on a pitch i need
this information instantly
they're like who is andy and i'm like
andy mcalpher she's the guy that i do
education with what's education this is
a show like cocktail party science we
got a [ __ ] fish in a bowl he's real
[ __ ]
depressed because he lives by himself in
a bowl he could talk sleep dudes like
this
i don't want to live no more please kill
me i pray to jesus
that jesus will come for me my ego
come i come and i breathe my almond milk
breathe it right in
[Music]
if they're breathing they breathe water
right it filters through their gills
so the fish swims into milk does it go
into its ga
like
i'm sure sure kevin that'll give you
something to think about
or can they pull oxygen from it is it
like you know if you're playing
playing a super mario game and you get a
mushroom does it make it more powerful
just like the power up is what it is
okay ask your why do people with
photographic memories
are they more depressed than others
because they can perfectly recall all of
their cringiest moments
i say no i say if you can remember
everything that means you remember the
good
we tend to remember the bad because
we're idiots and we focus on the
negative so imagine if you remembered
everything which means
all the good which you generally tend to
forget because it's easier to focus on
the bad
so i think if you had that power of
complete retention you'd be like mary
lou henner she lives up the hill for me
one of the nicest people in the world
always has a smile on her face why she
remembers every [ __ ] detail
you asked her about like day [ __ ]
four of episode
28 of working on taxi and what tony
danza said
she'll [ __ ] tell you she's like he
was like who's the boss and you're like
you're [ __ ] brilliant lady
how do you [ __ ] remember that [ __ ]
i've told you
i was working in nbc and she came into
my office by mistake
she goes oh i'm lost can you tell me how
to get back to reception
i'm like reception that you just walked
by that is within
sight of where you were standing
that's not the same as knowing what
color pants you wore
on [ __ ] just i don't know three
i don't know well the condition of
having
it's a memetic memory or highly superior
autobiographical memory is what they're
referring to as someone who remembers
everything that happens in their life
to them and they do say that people with
that
are more likely to feel depressed
because they think it's an ocd condition
that is similar to ocd and that they
find themselves caught in loops and it
and it becomes this uh perseverating
behavior wow man so
i was jealous of those who could [ __ ]
retain it all
but turns out [ __ ] blazing it all
away was the way to go
whole time yeah and what i did because i
don't smoke pot
is because i have a really good memory
and i remember all of the cringy moments
as i started to do a podcast with you so
that i could supplant those cringy
moments with hundreds and hundreds of
new cringy moments
you know what's cringy cringy moment is
a [ __ ]
is the whole world seeing this bird eat
the lower half of your face while you're
terrified
whip around and use your eyes to [ __ ]
stare right at this thing that's just
like
i mean you know how weird it is when
[ __ ] people look at you when you're
getting a blow job or if you're getting
eaten out like if you're getting eaten
out and they're like
looking up at you and if you're getting
a [ __ ] though i don't i don't
sure you do you know what i'm talking
about same thing with this [ __ ] fish
who's getting the half of the lower half
of his face he
he's literally looking in the eyes of
this [ __ ] bird and this bird's like
what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do except become bird
poop isn't that crazy
your one and only life that's it
no more milton for you man you're milton
in my [ __ ] body and then you become
[ __ ] literally my [ __ ] you are special
to someone
but you're becoming [ __ ] how weird is
that and you're gonna
think about this as i eat your lower
face i'm gonna do it slow
i might take a dump using your face
faster than i eat the top half of your
head i'm gonna keep you alive
you're [ __ ] flailing around anyway
and [ __ ] i'll be honest with you i don't
eat because i need
to i'm [ __ ] killed because
i'm a turn what bird was it an osprey
i'm an osprey [ __ ] and you ain't
ever gonna have no
offspring because i'm eating your lower
half of your face
and even if you manage to escape who's
gonna
[ __ ] you with no hello or have us us
pray to your god it won't do any good
you are going to be milton in your own
fins for the rest of your [ __ ] life
so you might as well stop moving and let
me eat the [ __ ] out of you first i'm
going to rip open your guts
let them fall on the ground and listen
first first they eat the bottom of their
face
yeah that first and then rip open your
gut
he knew about the face part it was
happening he didn't have to wait and
[ __ ]
he's like i'm gonna rip open your guts
the gut's falling around lesser birds
are gonna eat it and then what he eats
the meat yeah why don't he eat the guts
the osprey so yeah he can do whatever he
wants
he's like that's shit's nasty maybe he
had he might
eat he got to learn that from experience
he probably ate some things guts and had
poop in it he was like
i'm never doing that again and all those
other bird friends are like why don't
you eat the opal it's [ __ ] hot man
oh you [ __ ] be my guest one time i
eat a [ __ ] kidney full of piss
i had a mouthful of piss i could get
that taste out of my mouth for a [ __ ]
week man
my osprey wife wouldn't [ __ ] kiss me
and [ __ ]
i got her a jacket said osprey [ __ ] on
it she wouldn't wear it
okay the lord
hey man it's me kevin smith have you
been looking for all my old podcasts the
ones i started recording back in 2007
well guess what i found them they're all
hiding
in that kevin smith club see all the
video you've never seen including
exclusive movies and live
shows you want some swag that kevin
smith club is making pins
and miniature versions of my old scripts
you want to be involved in the least
exclusive
most inclusive club on the net join that
kevin smith club now's your chance
to club kevin smith
why let's get we're out of the y we you
know what it takes us to is the buy
oh my god that's right the buy the
finale man as carol burnette would say
um i'm so glad we had this time horsing
she would sing that's not say
you call that singing
what uh what jennifer lopez did at the
inauguration that's singing
you're like let me honor and destroy
carol burnett at the same time
i was giving her props but that is
overboard
people took her down a peg that beloved
american
entertainer i probably had a friend that
she grew up with that was funnier than
her
i would know she went on to be the uh be
the funny one
do you think so you think she was just
like oh my god my i bet you she thought
her grandmother was funnier than her
that's why she pulled on her ear yeah
that was always for a grandmother she
didn't yeah
all right so good night for grandma
watching such a charming story
wouldn't it be amazing if at the end of
her life when when god forbid
this worst of all possible worlds where
we don't have a carol burden anymore but
like they're like
she wanted this known after she died
every time she tugged on her ear it was
a huge
[ __ ] to follow people and they list the
names
and it's not even people like you know
old-timey [ __ ]
like it's it's it
covers a couple generations it's not
like
[ __ ] you lionel wagner it's not bad at
all
because she liked him yeah she liked
wonder woman so she was like yeah he did
did some good work but also he was on
the show with her as well oh i know i'm
saying though he went on to greatness
he went on to [ __ ] even better [ __ ]
than that you know what he did right
what he's really known for where he made
his fortune
i do star wagons that's right with two
g's
and you're uh in a trailer you're
[ __ ] inside lyle
wagner man yeah now wagner's like
stephen i have a wonderful idea i've
decided i'd like to collect the [ __ ] and
urine of
every famous person in hollywood so i'm
going to start building honey wagons
where they can [ __ ] and poo their [ __ ]
and pee and i will then collect the
honey wagon and bring it back to our
to our lot see i go the other way i
thought i think where he's a genius is
like he's like honey
i'm gonna create a place where the
actors will [ __ ]
they're gonna be covered in milt
everywhere
man we call milk wagons and she's like
why don't you call them star wagons
why don't you call them producers
couches like everyone else
darkness all right
sorry about that let's go back to the
beginning of the buy
no and the buy
is where we tell about talk about recent
stories in science that are fun and
interesting
poor example first one is
that octopus you know octopus have you
seen like my octopus teacher
that documentary and it's wonderful and
octopus
will often enlist the help of other fish
to hunt for fish in different crevices
and other things
well it turns out they just discovered
this behavior where
if the fish isn't helping them or gets
off uh
you know off topic they punch it in the
face
so octopus punch their helper fish in
the face
oh my god you should try that here next
time in person any time i'm like bye
you're like
what the [ __ ] anyway what were you
saying andy
octopus are they're strange i mean i
everyone should watch that series or
watch
anything about octopus and you tell me
or octopi
and you tell me they're from this planet
it is crazy i mean we did talk about
that in a recent education that there is
some evidence where people believe
because of their dna that they come
from another planet but they came here
frozen on a [ __ ] asteroid that
crashed into our oceans and then they
were frozen and they [ __ ] came to
life and they're like this is our new
home
started punching fish in the [ __ ]
face and they they spent
a millennia bullying fish bothering fish
they were fish bombers
which is what every bird wants to be
every bird that's been bothered by
andy's like i'm gonna become a fish
bother
and shows up in his window it's like
cool yeah
wow the octopus is talking monotone i'm
gonna talk like i'm from a 30s
gangster movie yeah
wow man [ __ ] punchy octopuses yeah
[ __ ] like i'm hungry you're not
paying attention
how about a like a a sucker sandwich
yeah man hey [ __ ] hey pay attention
it's like the george clooney slapping
people around in a movie and [ __ ]
not real life i don't know if he does
that in real life but yeah sure we don't
know
that he does that in real life but in
movies he's the kind of guy i don't even
know he's done it in the movie guys in
my little sketch
he is there's a lot of disclaimers [ __ ]
it's just like george clooney
although it's very much unlike him
in the george clooney movie that i can't
think of right now
all right what else have you ever
wondered
what would happen if you accidentally
swallowed like a little pin you would
use to pin stuff together to sew
what would happen to your body if you
swallowed it well a movie
really yeah it's [ __ ] intense bro
it's good movie
it's about this girl who like she's
married to this dude who's like a broker
or whatever [ __ ] he's in finance
and she lives in this like pristine
house and everything's perfect
and [ __ ] but like emotionally remote and
she starts eating
things and one of the things she eats is
a [ __ ] needle
she eats like a rock she eats like she
batteries she starts eating like [ __ ]
where they
look at her and she's got like a gut
full of metal and [ __ ] like that
oh it's it's a haunting move you should
watch it but wait so what happens when
you eat a
a needle is it don't necessarily well a
17 year old boy in germany found out
this summer
oh no why did he do it he was
sewing something and as i always say
never sew it's too dangerous
you can ride a motorcycle but don't sew
yeah he swallowed a pen he didn't
realize it
and then he started to complain and for
three days he had this very intense
chest pain
oh my god what do you have to do to shut
me up
lie down and it would hurt more and he
didn't know how to do it so they took
him to the doctor they gave to the
hospital they gave him an ecg an
electrocardiogram
oh god and they discovered that the pen
had found its way to stab him in the
heart
oh god i knew it [ __ ] i can't hear the
story oh this is horrible
[ __ ] how it came out of his what
trachea or something and when it
followed through and
found its way through his intestines and
it's stabbed into his heart and you know
what happened
don't the doctors
removed it within hours and he was
completely fine
you sure yes i'm positive that's exactly
what happened
so he got stabbed in the heart and lived
he did
from satan's from the depths of hell he
stabbed at him
and yeah i stabbed thee um at your heart
he uh wow that's [ __ ] that's
i mean sky's the limit at that point
right yeah so the next time you see your
kids sewing
you've got to be like where'd you learn
how to do it they'd be like i learned it
from you dad
let me tell you something right now guys
lucky to be alive
he is but he got good care
and it was a freak accident and he's
okay so that's all good
he swallowed it by accident by accident
he didn't even know he'd swallowed it
he was eating while he was doing it
that's why i tell my kids
never eat yeah never sew
or chew everything yeah oh my god
even then even if he was chilling and he
chewed on the pin and it went in his jaw
even that would hurt all of this is bad
the moral of the story
i think you're absolutely right never so
yeah
or if give it to somebody who
swallows swords professionally that way
in case they accidentally swallow the
pin
they'll know what to do don't don't sew
where you eat
nice there you go there you go that's
the thing
okay we have just one more in this i
mean this
this three and a half hours has flown by
with with this new
uh abridged edition and i just want to
tell you the last
story i think you're gonna like it i'm
ready for this it is about the little
beetle that could
um there is a beetle described it's
called
um regen bartia attenuita
and it lives in
japan and uh shinja
shigura of kobe university discovered
this behavior
that when it is swallowed by a pond frog
it makes its way all the way through the
pond frog
and pops out of its [ __ ] completely
fine
who what this beetle a beetle
that when the pound frog eats the beetle
the beetle goes
gets all the way through the frog and
pops out of its ass
and they think that in order to get out
of its ass it stimulates its ass to
think that it has to poo
and the and the frog poos it out and
it's fine it's like
why did the frog eat it because it was a
delicious little morsel
it's a tasty little treat so
it did eat it did get satisfied but it
didn't get the nutrients because this
thing
lived yeah it's like a it's like a diet
beetle
like frogs that are gaining a little
they should eat that
and it just comes flying out of their
butt um and they don't feel this
like this thing crawling through them
and [ __ ] i think that it
i don't think it even bothers them at
all because they just think that they're
pooping
so you're always talking about animals
turning into another animal's poop
yeah this thing just pretends to be poop
that's true
like andy dufresne crawled out of a
frog's [ __ ]
to get out of shawshank prison
wow and that beetle what make a movie
about that beetle
frog's [ __ ] to get out that's beetle
love love me do wait beetle or the
needle that's either or needle along the
way it stabs a heart just as it with a
little sewing needle
that's the name of the episode beetle
with a needle beetle or the needle
thanks i don't have to think of an
episode title now
there you go it's mimetic
does memetic mean uh uh
you're thinking of a mnemonic i think
what does mnemonic mean
mnemonic means something that you can
remember easily like
um twinkle twinkle little
well i mean you can remember that music
itself isn't mnemonic for
the lyrics people remember tunes uh it
helps them
remember things but i'm thinking more
like a like an acronym would be a
mnemonic like
homes for the great lakes huron
um what is the other ontario
uh michigan erie and superior
stuff like that an acronym like it's an
acronym but it's a mnemonic
it's a mnemonic mn one of the few words
that starts with mn
mnemonic mnemonic mnemonic
like the mnemonic plague like johnny
johnny mnemonic starring uh
greatest [ __ ] movie stars of all time
yeah um
that was that truly the word sonic
johnny mnemonic
yeah it finds its place in the annals of
uh
movie dumb by having a word that
that begins with mn did that word exist
before
cyberpunk yes
interest many things did cyberpunk
certainly
not as far as i'm concerned that's right
who's the most famous cyberpunk writer
of all time uh neil stevenson
johnny who wrote johnny to mine uh it's
not neil stevenson is it
it's uh it's the guy that wrote mona
lisa overdrive
uh and uh came up with the word
cyberpunk
and jacking in yeah yeah was that
nothing i know i can't think of his name
his work outlived the memory of his name
if only there were a mnemonic
to remember who wrote johnny
um walter
cronkite green just like and that's the
news
that is to today are we off camera
we enter a world of cyber warfare i'm
going to go and write some crazy [ __ ]
about a near post-apocalyptic world
i'm going to write the news now nobody
bother me
the man had a robot a hand in the heart
of a demon
the secret life of cronkite
cyber cronkite [ __ ] what is his name
dude i i'm gonna look it up if only
there were some
devices or there is cyberpunk i
mentioned
cyber walter something that's the name
that's
coming into my head
no cyberpunk no it's not that's why i
said stevenson it's
william gibson that's it it's they knew
there was a w
we were both wrong all together wrong
williams walter cronkite
now what is his name now william gibson
yeah william gibson he's the henry
gibson of
cyberpunk no he's the he's the edgar
allen poe
i mean he's like who's like him and then
who's the next person neil stephenson
he wrote some books that were good about
that stuff you're into cyberpunk you
read it
uh yes i read all those books i i loved
uh
i didn't love the sort of porn direction
that it took
with other writers but i did love
william gibson i thought he was a
visionary and many he named many things
like
cyber space was uh something named
but i was talking about neil stephenson
oh he wrote uh
like the cryptonomicon and you read that
yeah why would you read the
cryptonomicon
um you are neither cyber nor punk why
would you read that book because it was
an interesting book that takes place in
both world war ii
and modern day about setting up he was a
visionary
who predicted that bitcoin would become
vague oh my god there are
hidden depths that i didn't even know
about you that you've had a cyber punky
past
that's because they're hidden um you see
why don't you want to
talk to that i'll cop to it i don't you
know
you know me i'm easygoing but every time
i
every time you learn anything about me
it somehow turns back to like
buying a filthy jacket for my wife that
says something on it
this [ __ ] um
you know you could do a line of jeans
fish [ __ ] jeans
like they would sell people would be
like i want a fish [ __ ] on my ass
well i'm gonna curse you now you'll
never be able to watch superman
without hearing lex luthor say miss fish
[ __ ]
um do we have another one no i only
brought three
three but a derringer holds two minimum
oh well
um there it is kids derringer and a half
full of the buy
takes us to a two empty derringers
of the edumacation podcast for this week
man because we did
the four chambers we took our four shots
we were not giving away
our shots actually we did give away all
four shots we gave all of our shots away
so there were so there are no more shots
now we're just throwing the gun at you
and running and for some reason superman
always ducks
like you shoot him and it's like and
then you throw a gun he's like whoa what
the [ __ ] dude
because you might chip his tooth with
that really
yeah he don't want to get pistol whipped
he's like wow
that's the sound he makes is like owen
wilson playing him
wow that was close wow
he grew up to be a peanuts teacher
[Music]
what's that no
i don't need a ride home won't want mom
that's the peanuts peanuts in the
teacher
yeah series series with the what the
girl with the dragon tattoo sister
i just want to have sex with you so bad
teacher
whoa but i want to put this
tell me where you want it whoa
[Music]
what what
a teacher ah starring
the teacher from the peanuts
i don't know her name you know what the
you know what that voice is
he's just looking up at her the whole
time she's off camera
i wanna have sex with you a teacher well
i guess i can start down here on the
right height
but just as he's about to get some
she pulls it away and he ends up flying
away
a riveting portrait of
sex with an educator okay
i'll get your kite stuck in a tree if
you know what i'm saying
[Music]
do you know what the voice is oh sure
we'll stick it in your pigpen
what is the voice you want to tell it's
a it's a
a jazz trumpeter with a wawa thing on it
was that right
yeah nowadays they would [ __ ] like
you know put somebody in a booth
and then have a sound engineer and
rework it
no nowadays they would take a creature
whose bottom half of its face had been
eaten
while i was watching with the top of his
face and all it could the only sound it
could make was
you need two halves of your mouth to
make well you can't make a one
without you can use the thing that the
trumpeter used
on half his face and [ __ ] he's like it's
like it's a living
what would you have done with your life
if the lower half of your face hadn't
been eaten
what will not risk
why are you asking me this question
making me think about
it because i don't question it to ask
your
father who doesn't have a lower half of
his face and you know why
um they didn't get along oh he's got
your mother's eyes and your father's
lower half of his face
and the talk of the town is why did they
let it live
and they're like it's not an it like
well technically it is it's a fish
but still even in this world where we're
all anthropomorphic and [ __ ]
why did they let it live
something ate the lower half of its face
while he watched he's got to live with
that
not just the scars that is the mental
scar
the insult to injury is incalculable
because the bird pooped it out he
couldn't even go
find his [ __ ] jaw and put it back on
he knew that it was going to be poop
unless it was being pushed out of the
bird's [ __ ] by a beetle
then he got them beetles they crawl out
of [ __ ] and maybe he pushed his
lower chin out
no we should go look he's like oh
i found my lip ring
or he's like you know [ __ ] [ __ ] this
i'm not using this
clarinet thing no more
i want to steal the lower half of some
motherfucker's face and have it watch me
do it and so then he trains to be
like the bird that ate the lower half of
his face he was just doing it to survive
no malice or anything like that but this
fish
enacts the violence on others like on
purpose
becomes the james gum but just for the
lower half of faces
you know i mean he doesn't seem to
appreciate
maybe he'll get by the end of the movie
but he didn't need a lower half of his
face
the [ __ ] this thing it makes him
unique and memorable
nobody's gonna eat a fish that's [ __ ]
talking with one of these putting on a
show
he's got a whole backstory he just he
puts mr limpet to shame
yeah this fish is gonna live forever
like them kids and fame and [ __ ]
if he plays his cards right he's just
got to get right mentally
i know he carries a lot of metal scars
because he watched something eat the
lower half of his face
but all he needs to do is flip script
and remember that the eating of his
face made him be this guy and that
changed his life maybe the end of the
movie
is like he re-meets the bird and
we can come full circle with them face
to face
eye to eye and [ __ ] be like
you did me a favor and then the bird
goes
i never finished the job and he ripped
his guts out
he's like um seconds grip he's like oh
no this i've been hoisted on my own
plateau
at least i learned a valuable lesson
before i leave this world
take me next someone rip open my guts
although the goldfish would lose its
hand if something
ate the bottom of its face that's right
he would become this guy now i gotta
talk like this
breathing it go figure now i like it
it power ups me it gives you something
to do
now i aim for it oh god
uh there it is ladies
the silliest way to get super smart if
they had taught like this in high school
i'd be the brainiest person in the world
and they would be in prison i'd retain
it all no
we didn't say nothing bad man like just
cause a [ __ ] fish gets half its
face eating
that's nature we were giving our fish
half a chance like what happens if you
lay following the story on disney don't
give they're the ones to get mad at they
give you the fake [ __ ] death of the
lemons and [ __ ]
we're dealing in reality here we saw
fish get half of his face [ __ ]
we know it's possible and we know if
that fish got away
he might live without a lower half of
his face and how would he talk
all this is science you've you've
beautifully defended your thesis
mr smith that's right i recommend you i
don't want anyone [ __ ] ever
throwing that disney lemon [ __ ]
nobody squeezed no lemons
uh we do not squeeze any lemons ladies
and gentlemen
and that's probably the most harrowing
thing i learned tonight was that
disney was like we'll just [ __ ] get
them dizzy and they'll fall off
he was probably like just push them off
with a rake and they're like mr disney
that's killing him and then he's like
all right [ __ ] build a platform make
them dizzy and then they fall off
you feel better
mr disney why are you putting uh why are
you putting these
beds of nails around this the desk none
of your business
yeah because [ __ ] you know
look we've already built the disc let's
just see what that would look like
[ __ ] go flying into the nails and
[ __ ]
we're having lemon kabobs for dinner
they're like you're [ __ ] cruel and
like
no i'm the guy that made bambi bambi's
mother was killed in the first [ __ ]
ten
you think i give a [ __ ] about a lemon
you know the hunter was
me i killed baby yeah right off camera
that was me
and i giggled and i [ __ ] took my
shirt off and in the moonlight i bathed
in its blood
and i killed mary poppins kid's mom
and i yes every one of them characters
i'd give them motivation man
you know who ate nemo's mom and all his
little brothers all that [ __ ] milt
me
ten years after my death i took my
frozen head
that's like kept me alive so i can eat
all the [ __ ] heroes and parents of
every movie we
make because that's what motivates a
star
you don't get a star without a
motivation and the motivation is
i ate your [ __ ] mom poor
and i started with the bottom of her
face yeah looked right in her eyes
and i hit the lower half of her face and
i was like your son's gonna be
famous i know if that gives you mixed
feelings about all of this
i [ __ ] with her man
[Laughter]
before she left this world she had to
decide whether how she felt
about her own demise because it was
helping her son
and like a salmon that dies in the
stream and is later
eaten by the [ __ ] fish [ __ ] that it
laid before it died
that is the circle of life
from spilt milk you know nobody cries
over spilt milk man
and because of milt it's the circle jerk
of life
[Laughter]
it's the circle jerk
of life
we don't get as milky as we get ladies
and gentlemen without our favorite uh
[ __ ] professor andrew mcelveer not a
real professor
he keeps saying that but i think he's
only saying it for legal reasons
for rational reasons that he is a
professor i do anyway
when people ask me who's your friend
who's your smartest friend i say oh my
teacher friend my professor andrew
mcelfischer not a real professor
they'll be like he teaches and i was
like yeah man let me get this
do you know what [ __ ] fish comes
called
they're like wow he sounds great kevin
are you sure you're not talking about
jay i'm like jay didn't even notice
i told jay about milk because andy told
me because he's a professor
yeah i mean it's uh not a real professor
but it's like the uh the eskimos have 58
words for snow
jason muse has 160 words for com and he
didn't know melt
he didn't have milk man it was his was a
milk free world
should have given it to him at age 16 he
would have turned it into absolute
poetry and should
he beat nick that he was now he's all
grown up got a kid i could hand him milt
right now he'd be like that's [ __ ]
weird then he'd forget then on stage i'm
like milt right and he's like what are
you talking about i'm like it's [ __ ]
fish come you wouldn't remember that in
your [ __ ] teeth
he's like i'm not a kid anymore i've got
a [ __ ] five-year-old child and a wife
isn't it time we all grew up and stopped
doing this i'm like that's where the
money is
this is where we make the melt he's like
i thought milk was [ __ ] [ __ ] and i'm
like whatever
and it proves out that he's the smarter
of the two of us after all oh my god
um ladies and gentlemen
is education for this week i'm kevin
smith and i'm andy mcelfresh
and just at the end kevin froze
oh my god he froze you froze he
approached for me we'll do it again
that is education for this week i'm
kevin smith
and i'm andy mcelfresh and you have been
eduma milton yes you have